a report out this morning is prompting
new concerns about the safety of our
food the report claims recalls of
hazardous meat and poultry have gone up
83% in the last six years one in six
Americans get sick every year from
eating contaminated food with at least
3,000 deaths per year Salmonella alone
causes at least 450 deaths every year
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller spoke with one man who's
struggling after a recent e.coli
outbreak Michelle good morning he
certainly is good morning when you eat a
meal you want to make sure that it's
safe one researcher says recent recalls
of foods like lettuce beef and cereal
call food safety into question we spoke
with a grandfather from New York who
says a tainted salad forever changed
life with his wife was already set to
see her she's not ourselves
Benjamin Selig has been married to his
wife Karen for almost 55 years but in
October she went into septic shock the
75 year old tested positive for the same
strand of e.coli linked to romaine
lettuce we used to travel a lot we
traveled together
seelix says he believes his wife got
ecoli from contaminated lettuce at home
the grandmother of four spent weeks in
the hospital and now lives in a rehab
facility
he says she had a pre-existing kidney
condition but now needs dialysis three
days a week we should be able as
Americans to trust that the food we buy
is safe to eat
Adam Garber is a researcher for the US
Public Interest Research Group its
report found recalls of produce and
processed food by the FDA increased
about 2% from 2013 to 2018 and the most
hazardous meat and poultry recalls by
the USDA increased by more than 80
percent something is rotten in our
slaughterhouses in our fields and so
common-sense protections from farm to
fork can help prevent that the report
recommends the FDA required testing
water used for irrigation or watering of
pro
for hazardous pathogens like e.coli and
for meat and poultry products to clear
when antibiotic resistant strains of
Salmonella as an adulterant are found
there are opportunities to improve and
hold companies liable when they are
violating food safety plans the National
chicken Council told CBS News it hasn't
yet seen the report but says all chicken
is safe to eat when properly handled and
cooked and what significantly reduces
the threat of salmonella our food safety
plans at the USDA enforces they also
said any increase in recalls could be
attributed to tighter government
standards better testing and technology
the American Association of meat
processors said procedures and safety
plans are already in place to reduce
these risks of salmonella that's me
as for Karen Selig she might be able to
go home this weekend but life will be
very different so e-coli completely
changed the ballgame from you and
absolutely I mean she's she can't be
left alone at all anymore and I'm
hopeful that we can get her back through
some more normal existence and that's
what we're hoping for they certainly are
both the FDA and the USDA said they're
safety inspectors are still working
despite the partial government shutdown
and did not comment on the report the
produce Marketing Association declined
to comment without seeing the report
first if you'd like more information
about food recalls you can sign up for
alerts through the FDA and USDA and
asked your local store if they offer
alerts as well the real big issue here
is people who have already compromised
immune systems they're the most at risk
in fact mr. Selix sister-in-law she died
from ecolab she already had MS so it's
it's really tough for people who who
were already weak you know you certainly
feel as plain I'm glad that you pointed
out though that she's going home this
weekend looking forward to as well thank
you for sure well thank you Michele